hello and welcome to see a plain brown
store I think he plays a scotch if i
remember correctly scotch yes there were
some games against sir two games have
played I thought it was it was them we
had the regular scotch let's end of the
Scotch four nights this is a good line
here for white a very safe kind of kind
of game and um it's and not something
where like gets many chances to be
active not bad not bad at all so can I
do this or am I too weak here it looks
like i can play it now
didn't want some buyers coming do I
Cooper should be seven here or not not
clear to me I think I rather go to a
six-foot I'm probably exposed to some
night air for later take sex lightly
form at least I played some somewhat
quickly that looks good Jim to see place
you for here soonish I don't know I'm
kind of running out of a useful move
someplace oh I'm taking it's a bit of a
concession actually to give him this
night move which I did I didn't see any
um any good useful improving move
anymore
this is some trickery here my Korean is
unprotected this is always kind of
concerning 95 no way I can actually take
it 95 won't work this one okay I mean I
probably have to do this anyway so kind
of useless to to spend time this is an
interesting interesting power structure
but lesser called standards you would
say that should be good for black but
potentially you can play 93 here always
and yeah I mean and and be an annoyance
there on the dark squares on the pawns
can I do this actually here it's all is
that crazy force the issue on 93 I can
take 97 I don't know 96 I think it's not
great there he goes there so I was
sending taking and here my dear Bishop
f5 which might be not working at all due
to tactics this one oh but this should
be okay this should be really okay I
have Bishop g7 can just trade down if
the bishop ending is very okay for black
there the pawn structure is more
important i mean that i have it on dark
that i have those dark squared in the
bonds on dark squares
I'm trying the same um so let's take I
came here for I have six I kick the kick
of the rook out maybe Bishop f5 as a
move here yeah hey that's a good move
that's a good move should could have
played to avoid that somehow I'd have to
trade the bishops now that's terrible I
mean not terrible in like Ambrose but I
cannot cannot play for an edge anymore
hmm or am I were Sam
yeah i wonder if i should play a 4 here
let's do it i don't want to sit down
check the spawn that looked a cat quite
unimportant check
good story somewhat critical for four
wide time morning check guys going to
chick okay but here 53 seconds is also
not so bad check so there are some
almost suits one's here right if i go
here threatening okay for it's quite
funny check check check so i have to cut
the king I'm going here so that he
doesn't have the phone to check that
easily check
looks like you see in a position
check quite resigned yeah so 0 about the
only way you can can win against this
line I try to write out some ending this
is a super solid thing for white really
so totally totally solid okay so c4d
form and now here I okay this was a bit
of a drastic decision but I wanted to
wanted to get this ending and when I try
to argue is that his bishops is the
pudding it's on the same squares as the
pawns but he gets this in the rook c8 is
supposed to be more precise interesting
yeah maybe this is actually layer this
is actually winning a tempo maybe yeah
almost almost like take Bishop d7 is
coming so might be more precise IAM the
the problem is that Bishop f5 is a good
move and it could have done it right
here actually ma'am this this is this is
solving all things for why am I think
here it will probably be a draw with a
form i have to be a bit cautious if he
if he gets to enter it might be worse so
i probably have to go away for want to
play this this kind of thing which
probably trades down to nothing at the
end here yeah it's still as bishop at
five and here i mean this is this is
just equal i think yeah if force I think
you
for our useful I'm a good decision at
least the way it turned out I was
surprised that he went for the H porn
that H point looked unimportant at the
moment and travis's thought giving me
some chances yeah king of three was
stronger yeah it gets it gets to be
critical kh4 was good I mean I'm not
surprised that the engine find some some
better options but okay yeah I can give
kinky five why don't I play kinky
five-year that's funny that's sometimes
I had seen that that this is good of
course and I didn't really look but King
g5 is stronger the problem is he is in a
somewhat weird situation he has
difficult for him to keep this porn
probably cannot really look f3 King
defog a3 was even stronger check check
so yeah I was thinking the ostrich
should should win actually yeah I'm
cutting him off yeah it's a win I think
it's a winner don't see a defense is cut
off cat I the stock fish a tener que lo
base so it's um it's um to rely on its
evil and
what I think I think I'm winning with
the Jeep one okay guys yeah thanks for
watching